why can't he let us do something
different just once
let's be a real Ariel without your
sisters you would never have made it
onto dry land to marry Prince Eric if
your dad aka King Triton only had one
daughter he never would have let you go
he would have been forced to live out
your days as a mermaid collecting things
from the human world thanks to your
sisters King Triton was able to give you
legs and let you live happily ever after
there are a lot of forgotten siblings in
the Disney verse and some never even
made it into the movies at all if you've
ever wondered what would have happened
if Belle sisters stayed in the picture
or if Moana had brothers you're not
alone
watch until the end to find out about a
surprising Disney Villains sister Ariel
sisters let's start with our favorite
Disney Princess from under the seed
Ariel has six beautiful sisters with
lovely singing voices Ariel sisters
appeared briefly in the Little Mermaid
but their impact when the story was very
important King Triton was very
protective of his daughters especially
Ariel if her sisters hadn't kept their
father so busy he would have been a
total helicopter parent to Ariel can you
imagine if she had been an only child
Triton would have never let her out of
his sight but a dad with seven daughters
is too busy to keep his youngest from
wandering off Ariel was able to sneak
away long enough to become fascinated
with the human world
why Erik run away with you if it weren't
for Ariel's sisters there's no way King
Triton would have let Ariel shed her
mermaid tail to live on land and marry
Prince Erik her sister's made it all
possible honza's brothers let's move out
of the sea and journey to the southern
Isle to discuss the siblings of the
shady frozen villain Hans in the movie
Hans tells on it twelve older brothers
that puts his position in line for the
throne at number thirteen as a result of
his unfortunate place at the back of the
royalty line he resorts to evil
to get the upper hand but do you ever
wonder what Hans would have been like if
he didn't have all those older brothers
would he have been a villain he would
have received a lot more attention from
his parents and we're just speculating
here but we're under the impression that
Hans didn't have the nicest family he
probably got picked on a lot it's
horrible
that would make anyone desperate to
change their situation still that's no
excuse for what he did to Anna but it
does help to understand why someone acts
the way they do maybe he'll learn to
stand up to his brothers since his
diabolical plan to trick on into
marrying him didn't work out there's
another villain on our list who has a
long-lost sister keep watching to find
out who it is lo Ana's brothers speaking
of brothers did you know that Moana was
originally going to have nine brothers
in the movie that's right in the early
stages of Moana her nine brothers sailed
out to sea from the shores of Montana we
leaving Moana on the island Moana was to
go on a quest to rescue them
Disney scrapped that concept and changed
it to a race between Moana and her
brothers which she was supposed to win
in the end they cut the brothers
entirely and set Moana to a seaward
adventure all on her own well it would
have been fun to see mo Ana's nine
brothers it might have distracted us
from the hero's journey ultimately
Disney's decision was best for the film
Clarice originally in Beauty and the
Beast Belle was going to have a sister
named Clarice in the alternate opening
to Beauty and the Beast we see Belle
sister Clarice playing in the yard of
her father's mansion while Belle's
father pushes her on a swing they later
decided to cut Clarice's role because
they wanted to emphasize Belle's
loneliness there's no one I can really
talk to
with no sister to play with Belle turned
a book who knows how the story would
have played out if Belle had a younger
sister to look after she may not have
decided to stay at Beast castle as his
prisoner in place of her father she
might not have been open to loving the
Beast if she had the love of her sister
still we would love to know what Clarice
was like do you think she was a sweet
little sister or would she have been a
troublemaker we
we'll never know Harris Huber and Hamish
the following Disney siblings definitely
fallen the troublemaker category Merida
from Disney Pixar's brave has three
triplet brothers Parris Huber and Hamish
in the movie they were constantly
playing pranks stealing treats and
getting into mischief but Merida loves
her brothers in fact she is the only one
who can tell them apart Merida can
hopefully teach her younger brothers how
to be courageous and channel their
naughty behavior into a healthy thirst
for adventure it's hard to imagine
Merida being an only child we love how
much humour and fun the triplets bring
to her story
Morgana did you know that the Little
Mermaid's Ursula has a sibling
her name is Morgana and she is just as
evil as her older sea witch sister she
was the main villain in disease mm
direct-to-video sequel The Little
Mermaid to return to the sea where Ghana
was determined to get revenge on Ariel
and Eric for the demise of her sister
Ursula but instead she gets trapped in a
block of ice that sinks to the bottom of
her crumpled sea cave these evil
tentacled sea witches just can't catch a
break who's your favorite sibling on
this list tell us in the comments
subscribe to the things to stay up to
speed on our latest Disney videos and
while you're at it hit that thumbs up
button thanks for watching bye
[Music]